Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
L’écrivain irlandais George Bernard Shaw
nous dit avec humour :
«Il y a deux tragédies dans la vie.
La première, c'est de ne pas obtenir
ce qu'on désire ardemment.
Et la seconde, c’est de l’obtenir.»
On en fait tous l’expérience
depuis qu’on est enfant :
on est en souffrance de ne pas
avoir les jouets qu’on veut
et dès qu’on les a, on s’en lasse
et on regarde les jouets de ses voisins,
de son petit frère, de sa petite sœur.
L’être humain est
un perpétuel insatisfait.
Ce qui faisait dire à Arthur Schopenhauer,
ce grand philosophe du 19ᵉ siècle,
quelque chose de beaucoup plus tragique :
«Toute l’existence humaine
oscille tel un pendule, de gauche
à droite, de la souffrance à l’ennui.
On souffre de ne pas avoir ce qu’on désire
et dès qu’on l’a, on s’ennuie
et donc on va désirer à nouveau,
et on souffrira à nouveau
jusqu’à qu’on obtienne.
On sera satisfait un temps
et on s’ennuiera.»
Évidemment, c’est une vision
très pessimiste,
mais il y a quelque chose
de profondément vrai,
parce que l’être humain
a cette caractéristique
qui le distingue des autres animaux,
c’est que nous sommes
dans un désir infini.
Le caractère du désir
chez l’être humain est infini.
Chez les animaux, on l’observe,
lorsque leurs besoins
fondamentaux sont satisfaits,
lorsqu’ils ont ce dont ils ont besoin,
en termes de sécurité, etc.
ils ne cherchent pas autre chose.
Même lorsqu’il y a
un appétit de domination,
un grand singe, une fois, qu’il domine
sur son territoire, sur son clan,
il ne va pas chercher à conquérir
la savane entière.
Alors qu'un être humain qui a un appétit
de domination, un désir de domination,
une fois qu’il domine dans son village,
il veut dominer dans le village d’à côté.
Puis dans tout le pays.
Puis dans le continent.
Puis la Terre entière
et l’univers s’il pouvait.
Les dictateurs n’ont aucune limite
à leur désir de domination.
Et c’est vrai pour tout.
Nous n’avons aucune limite
dans le désir de connaissance.
Nous ne nous satisfaisons pas simplement
de connaître ce qui est nécessaire
à notre survie,
comme la plupart des animaux,
Nous avons besoin de connaître
d’où nous venons.
Qu’est-ce que la matière ?
L’atome ? Les étoiles ? etc.
Donc l'être humain a une soif infinie,
un désir infini.
Platon a essayé de définir
cette caractéristique du désir.
Il dit au fond, à travers Le Banquet,
dans la bouche de Socrate,
que nous désirons ce que nous n’avons pas,
ce que nous ne sommes pas,
ce qui nous manque.
Et donc, il y a comme un manque
fondamental chez l’être humain.
Pour Platon, c’est parce que
nous avons été séparés du divin
et que donc nous avons
une aspiration à retrouver le Divin.
Tant que nous ne l’aurons pas retrouvé,
nous allons désirer toutes sortes
de choses matérielles
ou de personnes qui seront des ersatz
de notre désir profond,
qui est un désir d’infini.
Ce que nous disent
les scientifiques aujourd’hui,
qui est une sorte d’explication
plus rationnelle que Platon,
même s’il y a quelque chose
qui peut être vrai chez Platon,
on n’en sait rien,
ce sont les études des neurosciences
qui étudient le cerveau.
Qu’est-ce qu’on découvre ?
C’est que, dans notre cerveau primaire,
qu’on appelle le striatum,
nous avons des impulsions fondamentales,
des besoins, des désirs fondamentaux.
Il y en a quatre, c’est le désir de se
reproduire, donc le désir de sexualité,
le désir de nourriture,
le désir d’information
et le désir de statut social.
Ces quatre désirs fondamentaux
sont le moteur de nos vies.
En fait, nous sommes en permanence
poussés à rechercher du sexe,
de la nourriture, de l’information
et du statut social.
Que se passe-t-il lorsque nous obtenons
ce que notre cerveau nous pousse à faire ?
Eh bien, nous avons du plaisir à travers
une substance chimique, la dopamine.
Et la dopamine est libérée
chaque fois que nous obtenons ce que nous
pousse à obtenir notre cerveau primaire.
C’est ce qu’on appelle le circuit
de la récompense.
Le philosophe Henri Bergson nous disait :
«Le plaisir est une ruse que la nature
a inventée pour la survie de l’espèce.»
Parce qu’au fond, si on n’avait pas
de plaisir à manger, à faire l’amour,
à avoir de l’information pour survivre,
ou à avoir une certaine reconnaissance,
l’espèce se serait éteinte.
Donc le plaisir est le moteur
de nos existences,
à la fois collectives, depuis des dizaines
de milliers d’années, et individuelles.
Alors tout ça, effectivement,
fait que nous passons notre temps
à rechercher du plaisir
puisque nous avons ce shoot de dopamine
chaque fois que nous obtenons
quelque chose
que nous recherchons instinctivement,
sans en avoir conscience.
C’est tout à fait fondamental,
ces quatre désirs.
Ce shoot de dopamine crée
une addiction à la dopamine.
Ce que nous recherchons ensuite,
c’est le plaisir permanent
apporté par la dopamine,
par n’importe quel moyen.
Aujourd’hui, ça peut être
les réseaux sociaux.
On le voit dans leur évolution,
quand c’était Facebook, les vidéos
duraient assez longtemps, etc.,
Instagram, c’est de plus en plus court
et TikTok, c’est quinze secondes.
C’est-à-dire, plus ça va, plus ceux
qui ont créé les réseaux sociaux
ont compris que les adolescents
ont besoin de plein de plaisirs,
de petits shoots de dopamine immédiats.
C’est pour ça qu’on leur envoie
des notifications.
Il faut sans arrêt susciter
leur attention.
Il faut sans arrêt renouveler ce plaisir
qu'ils recherchent à travers la dopamine.
Donc on est devant cette situation
où le cerveau humain est ainsi configuré.
Et puis évidemment,
ça crée aussi de la convoitise
parce que nous désirons
ce que les autres possèdent.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que nous sommes
dans la comparaison sociale.
Nous avons besoin de statut social
et donc nous nous comparons aux autres.
Et tout le système capitaliste est fondé
là-dessus, sur la comparaison sociale.
Les publicitaires dans les années 1920 aux
États-Unis ont parfaitement compris ça.
Il y a un rapport qui a été remis
au président Hoover qui dit :
«Nous avons compris comment
fonctionne la psychologie humaine.
L’être humain se compare
et si nous voulons vendre nos produits
de manière incessante, sans fin,
il faut créer sans cesse
de nouveaux besoins
en jouant sur la comparaison sociale.»
Monsieur, vous avez
une Ford six cylindres,
votre voisin une Ford douze cylindres.
Qu’attendez-vous pour avoir
une de ces grosses voitures comme lui ?
Même si on n’a pas besoin
d’avoir une 12 cylindres
pour rouler avec une vitesse limitée.
Peu importe, en jouant sur la comparaison
sociale, on va créer de nouveaux besoins.
Madame, votre frigidaire fait 300 litres,
votre voisine, 600 litres.
Qu’attendez-vous pour demander à votre
mari d’acheter un frigidaire de 600L ?
Texto, c’est dit comme ça.
Et donc au fond, on joue en permanence
sur la comparaison sociale
pour nous faire consommer.
Et nous sommes prisonniers de ce système
qui dure depuis plus d’un siècle,
dans lequel nous voulons toujours plus
et nous ne sommes jamais satisfaits.
Alors, face à cette situation
qui est aujourd’hui dramatique
parce qu’on sait qu’évidemment la survie
de notre planète en dépend
et qu’il faut sortir de
ce consumérisme permanent
et de ce fonctionnement
de notre cerveau primaire.
Qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire ?
En même temps, c’est un fonctionnement
qui a toujours existé.
Il faut mettre de la conscience.
Il faut arriver à mettre
de la conscience sur nos désirs
pour pouvoir sortir de ce fonctionnement
totalement mécanique.
Et c’est pour ça d’ailleurs
que les philosophes de l’Antiquité,
toutes les religions du monde,
depuis des milliers d’années,
nous disent : «Attention,
le désir humain, s’il n’est pas limité,
s’il n’est pas encadré,
s’il n’est pas maîtrisé,
il est dangereux.
Il va conduire à toutes les guerres,
à toutes les violences.»
C’est pour ça que,
dans la Bible, il est dit :
« Tu ne convoiteras
pas l’âne de ton voisin,
le serviteur ou la maison de ton voisin.»
Et que dans le bouddhisme,
on dit qu’il faut quitter
l’attachement lié au désir
et qu’il faut diminuer le désir.
Dans le stoïcisme, il s’agit
de supprimer le désir,
qu’il faut transformer en volonté.
Il faut que le désir ne soit pas
simplement une pulsion affective,
mais quelque chose de rationnel
et de possible.
Et donc, on voit que toutes les sagesses
de l’Antiquité nous invitent à diminuer
ou à limiter le désir,
parce qu’il conduit d’une part au malheur
de l’être humain, toujours insatisfait,
et qu’il conduit à de la violence sociale.
Est-ce une solution ?
Moi, ça ne me motive pas trop.
Et je suis beaucoup plus
en accord avec Spinoza,
ce grand philosophe du 17ᵉ siècle,
qui nous dit qu’il ne faut surtout pas
diminuer le désir.
Il ne faut surtout pas limiter le désir,
il ne faut surtout pas supprimer le désir,
parce que le désir,
c’est l’essence de l’homme.
Sans désir, on n'a plus envie
de se lever le matin.
On se lève le matin
parce qu’on a des désirs.
Pourquoi est-on motivé dans la vie ?
Car on a des désirs.
Ce qui nous rend heureux,
c’est d’être désirant.
Nous sommes des êtres de désir,
c’est l’essence humaine.
Je crois que c'est profondément vrai.
Simplement, il s’agit d’apprendre à mettre
de la conscience sur nos désirs
et à bien les orienter.
Donc ne supprimons surtout pas le désir.
Ne le limitons pas.
Apprenons par la raison,
par la réflexion, à bien l’orienter.
Et cela d'autant plus que bien souvent,
nos désirs ne sont pas nos désirs.
Nos désirs ne sont pas personnels,
nous imitons les désirs des autres.
Ce que le grand anthropologue René Girard
appelait le désir mimétique.
Nous désirons ce que les autres désirent
parce que nous avons besoin
de modèles à imiter.
Et donc, un enfant va désirer
ce que ses parents désirent
et c’est comme ça qu’il va grandir.
L’éducation se fait à travers
le désir mimétique.
Un adolescent va être en contradiction
avec les désirs de ses parents.
Il voudra l'inverse.
Mais que va-t-il faire ?
Il va imiter le désir de ses copains.
Pour être intégré
et reconnu dans le groupe,
il sera aussi dans le désir mimétique.
Il voudra les mêmes paires de chaussures,
les mêmes marques,
les mêmes objets que ses copains.
Et ensuite, un jeune adulte va imiter
ce que son patron désire
parce qu’il va vouloir accéder
à tel statut social, etc.
Nous sommes pris en permanence dans le
désir mimétique et dans toute la société,
et dans toute société.
Dans toute société humaine, nous imitons
les désirs collectifs des autres.
Si nous voulons aujourd’hui
être reconnus socialement,
nous allons avoir une belle montre
qui vaut une fortune
ou un gros 4X4 parce que ce sont les
objets désirés par la majorité des gens,
parce que, bien sûr,
la publicité nous a montré
que ces objets avaient une certaine
valeur de reconnaissance sociale.
Et donc, tout ça fait que nous imitons
les désirs collectifs d’une société
dans laquelle nous vivons,
et c’est valable pour
toutes les époques et sociétés.
Sauf que les objets du désir
ne sont pas les mêmes, ils changent.
Je pense que dans 20 ans,
ce sera complètement ringard d’avoir une
montre qui vaut une fortune ou un 4X4,
ne serait-ce que pour la raison écologique
qui fait qu’il est nécessaire de réduire
effectivement notre consommation.
Et donc, si nous sommes pris
dans le désir mimétique,
la question c’est : comment accéder
à nos désirs personnels ?
Parce que ce qui nous rend heureux,
profondément,
c’est d’avoir accès
à nos désirs singuliers.
Et le grand psychologue suisse
Carl Gustav Jung nous dit :
«L’être humain à un moment donné,
au milieu de la vie, entre 35 et 50 ans,
fait une crise appelée la crise
du milieu de la vie qui est nécessaire.»
Et c’est ce qu’il va appeler
le processus d’individuation.
Comment vais-je devenir l’individu
singulier que je suis ?
Quels sont mes désirs personnels ?
Suis-je banquier
parce que papa était banquier
ou suis-je pianiste
parce que papa était pianiste ?
Me suis-je marié avec telle personne
parce que j’étais conditionné
par ma famille ?
Quels sont mes désirs
les plus personnels ?
Et beaucoup de gens,
effectivement, entre 35 et 50 ans,
font une crise au bon sens du terme,
c’est-à-dire une remise en question
qui leur permet de se dire :
« Qui suis-je vraiment ? »
« Ai-je fait les bons choix ? »
« Suis-je dans une activité que j’aime ? »
« Quels sont mes désirs personnels ? »
Et c'est à partir de là qu'on peut
souvent réorienter sa vie.
Vous avez beaucoup de gens entre
35 et 50 ans, qui changent de vie
et qui vont faire un métier
complètement différent,
qui vont se reconvertir
professionnellement, qui vont divorcer,
parce qu’ils sont à l’écoute
de leurs désirs personnels.
Donc, c’est très important d’être dans
ce désir de savoir qui je suis vraiment
et qu’est-ce qui peut me rendre heureux.
Et Spinoza nous dit qu’il faut apprendre
à réorienter nos désirs
vers ce qui nous met dans la joie.
La joie, c'est le critère.
Qu’est-ce qui me met dans la joie ?
Certes, manger etc. me donne du plaisir.
Mais qu’est-ce qui me met dans la joie ?
La joie, c’est beaucoup
plus profond que le plaisir.
Et ça, c'est la juste orientation
de nos désirs.
La joie du corps, c’est la santé.
Quels sont les aliments
qui me mettent en bonne santé ?
Alors, je peux désirer boire
des sodas toute la journée.
C’est très agréable,
ça me donne du plaisir,
mais ça me ruine la santé.
Donc, allons chercher quels sont les
aliments qui nous mettent en bonne santé,
quand je me sens bien après avoir mangé.
Et puis on fait ça aussi
dans la vie amoureuse.
Quelles sont les personnes
qui me conviennent ?
Comment orienter mon désir
vers des choses, des personnes,
des idées qui me conviennent,
qui sont justes pour moi
et qui donc vont me faire grandir
et me mettre dans la joie ?
Tout est une question
d’orientation de nos désirs.
Il ne faut pas supprimer
la force du désir.
Il faut apprendre à bien
orienter nos désirs.
Et d’autres philosophes,
comme Nietzsche et Bergson,
qui sont profondément spinozistes,
nous disent à la suite de Spinoza
que le désir, c’est l’élan vital,
la force vitale.
Nietzsche, par exemple,
va nous dire, dans Zarathoustra,
qu’il faut aller non pas vers
ces petits désirs de sécurité,
d’avoir quelque chose qui nous rassure.
Il nous dit que le dernier homme,
il ne pensera plus qu’à sa santé,
ce sera son ultime désir.
Il faut aller vers le grand désir.
Qu’est-ce qui nous fait grandir ?
Qu’est-ce qui nous rend pleinement
vivant, pleinement humain,
quitte à prendre des risques ?
Et donc, Nietzsche, face au petit désir,
nous propose le grand désir,
et Bergson nous parle de l’élan vital
et nous dit que toute l’aventure
de la vie,
de l’univers est traversée
par un élan créateur, un élan vital.
Nous pouvons nous connecter
à cet élan vital.
Comment ?
D’une part par le contact avec la nature,
parce que la nature est traversée
par cet élan vital
qui fait que le printemps, à chaque fois,
permet à la vie de repartir.
C'est un miracle permanent sous nos yeux.
Quand on se connecte à la nature,
on se connecte à l’élan vital
qui traverse l’univers.
On le voit dès qu’on est fatigué, épuisé,
il suffit de s’allonger sur l’herbe,
de s’adosser à un arbre,
de marcher dans la nature,
de regarder un beau paysage.
Immédiatement, on se ressource
et cet élan vital nous fait grandir.
Et puis la créativité, le fait d’être
créatif, nous relie à l’élan vital.
Donc orienter nos désirs
vers des activités artistiques,
ou vers toute forme de créativité,
si vous allez chanter,
jouer de la musique ou danser,
ça vous mettra dans la joie.
Ça cultive votre vitalité.
Un chef d’entreprise peut être créatif,
un cuisinier peut être créatif,
dans tous les domaines ou presque,
on peut mettre de la créativité
et la créativité nous met dans cet élan
vital qui nous met dans la joie.
C’est pour ça que Spinoza nous dit
encore que c’est aussi essentiel
lorsqu’on est malheureux,
lorsqu’on est dans une addiction,
c’est parce que nos désirs
sont mal orientés.
Si j’oriente mon désir vers la bouteille,
vers la drogue, vers le jeu,
ou que vers le sexe,
je serai toujours malheureux.
Mon désir est mal orienté.
Mais on ne peut pas quitter
un désir mal orienté, une addiction,
par la seule force de la raison
ou de la volonté.
C'est impossible.
Un alcoolique, il va vous dire :
« Je sais, je dois arrêter
de boire, mais je n’y arrive pas.
Je veux mais je ne peux pas.»
Et donc, la raison et la volonté ne
suffisent pas à réorienter nos désirs.
Qu’est-ce qu’il faut ?
Il faut susciter un nouveau
désir vers un affect
encore plus fort que celui
qu’on veut contrarier.
Donc on ne pourra quitter
un désir mal orienté, ou une addiction,
que parce qu’on trouvera une motivation,
un désir vers quelque chose,
vers une personne,
vers une activité artistique,
tomber amoureux.
Un affect qui nous donnera
cette force désirante
et qui fait qu’on pourra quitter
quelque chose qui nous rend malheureux.
Je connais des adolescents qui
ont quitté la drogue ou l’alcool
parce qu’ils ont appris à monter à cheval,
ils sont en lien avec la nature,
ils ont développé une activité artistique,
ils sont tombés amoureux,
soit, des activités qui nous élèvent,
qui nous font du bien.
Et là, on voit bien que nos désirs
peuvent être orientés
soit vers l’avoir, posséder toujours plus,
et je n’ai rien contre
le fait de posséder,
mais c’est sans fin,
ça nous rend malheureux
et ça détruit la planète.
Ou alors, nos désirs peuvent
être réorientés vers l’être :
vers la connaissance, l’amour,
l’art, le partage, la communion,
un tas de choses qui nous élèvent
et qui nous rendent profondément heureux
car ça nous met dans la joie
et en plus, ça ne coûte rien.
Donc, ce que nous avons à faire,
je pense, aujourd’hui,
d’autant plus, vu la crise écologique
dans laquelle nous sommes,
c’est d’apprendre à réorienter nos désirs,
à les cultiver,
surtout ne pas les diminuer
et à les réorienter vers
des désirs de l’être.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)